okay
here we go
there it is
[Music]
okay ladies and gentlemen
welcome to another live episode of
this is
[Music]
wow
[Music]
staying alive
[Music]
all right what's up y'all
welcome to roofing with griffin i hope
it's good i hope you uh
you know hope you enjoy thank you for
being here it is what it is
it is what it is rhythm with griffin
live you know i often go live when i
just too busy on the weekend and i can't
get an episode in but you know it is
what it is i hope it uh comes out good i
hope it sounds good i hope i'm clear
um
hey so what's happening uh thanks for
being here if you're listening uh you're
listening to listening later you're
listening to a live recording of the
podcast
noon august 23rd which is today uh the
chat is live on youtube right now so i
see the chat in front of me right now so
welcome chad thanks for being here um
you know and i'm doing it by myself
wiggy's not here today uh it's just i
just been going through like you know
it's just been a real busy busy busy
busy time
yeah so make sure you hit the like
button and thanks for being here uh make
sure you share subscribe catch me live
on twitch too uh
eric griffin gaming i do that i put
those videos
up on youtube
at eric griffin gaming along with you
know i you know i'm live on eric griffin
gaming so if you want to go on there
subscribe support the show i really
appreciate that
so you know here we are so thanks for
being here once again like i said i hope
this is looking good uh sounding good i
mean you know when it's a live recording
you have like a lot of things that can
go wrong so you know we're just going to
try to make it happen but again once
again if you're listening on apple it
itunes and all that kind of stuff thanks
for listening every single week and
thanks you know help me support the
support show share you know it's like i
got a small crowd of people that
listen to me and follow me and i really
appreciate it it's uh you know it's just
my thoughts you know a lot of times uh
you know we get disagreements you have
people that say whatever they're gonna
say
you know but it is what it is you know
i've been doing king and the sting a lot
and that's like a bigger podcast so you
know you get like a lot of like people
hitting you up and i talk about that on
king and distinct a lot about like the
haters like i don't understand but you
know but whatever it is what it is i
mean i do understand because it's the
nature of like the internet i get it but
i do want to say after the last episode
i did and i'll probably say this on king
of stinks i'm going on there again
tomorrow is that i i actually got an
outpouring of love from the king and the
sting fans and so i really do appreciate
that people were sending me messages
don't worry about the haters and then it
was like of course because then i
started to think about it i was like
yeah there is actually is more love than
there is hate so um
so it is what it is
so
let's not even uh worry about it um so
you know i just want to get you guys
caught up thanks for watching last
week's episode with paulie shore i was
in vegas and i was doing that live
no i'm not live but i recorded at
paulie's house
uh you know he's such a character a very
sweet guy uh you know it's like that
character that he has it's not really
who he is
and i think that when he's on my podcast
he kind of like more of himself comes
out so that that was a fun episode and
it was weird being in vegas last week i
mean vegas uh re-reinstated not vegas
but i think all of nevada reinstated
their
mask mandate for covet and it just to me
seems ridiculous this is just my
thoughts about it i'm not an
anti-massacre or anything like that i'm
vaccinated what i do is i just don't go
out a lot i just try to stay indoors
because if i don't like wearing a mask
then i know i'm not going to be around
people i go to my shows which is a
different thing
you know you go to the shows then i go
home i just don't find myself going to a
lot of places because i just don't want
to deal with that it makes me
uncomfortable i just i just don't like
it
but that's just you know that's neither
here nor there that's up to you it ain't
a political thing it's my own personal
like you know it's like i feel
restricted i i hate that thing you know
what i mean
uh but it's like to me
like when you go to a place like vegas
though it just seems weird to me first
of all there's no there's no um capacity
restrictions so you know you could be 70
000 people at watching the raiders
just you know you know even though
that's outdoors uh i don't even think it
is outdoors i think the raider stadium
isn't indoors it probably is because for
air conditioning it'll be too damn hot
um
you know you go to like the thomas and
mac center and it's like the place is
full of people uh my show was full of
people the casino is just full of people
and so i don't know what like this is
for i mean i think i don't know if
they're doing it for health and safety
or if they're doing it for liability if
they're doing it for like we got to make
people think we're doing something
because my thing is like the agreement
to me is you're going to vegas if you go
to vegas then it's like all right i want
to drink gamble
you know whatever all the bad stuff that
happens there all the debauchery that
kind of stuff that happens there if you
want to gamble away your kids college
fund if you want like whatever you're
making an agreement that i'm coming here
to this sort of unsafe environment and
if something happens that's on me
like take some personal responsibility
it's on me
so it's i just think that we're going to
get to a point where it's going to be
waivers have to be signed it's going to
be like you know how like when you see
like a a
a a recording of like a like a show or
something and you don't know what's
recording and they say you walk in the
door and it'll be like you know if you
walk in the door you are agreeing that
you know you it's okay for you to be
recorded they don't even need to
get people's signature because they're
letting people know you might be on
camera i think it's gonna have to be the
same kind of thing like when you buy
your ticket to vegas or you cross into
the border it should be a sign that says
hey you are entering a place where you
might get covet uh you know good luck
and then we just move on with our lives
at certain places
and even on a smaller scale
when you go to like
a comedy club this is another thing that
really ticks me off because i think i've
talked about this already but i don't
care you know you go to a comedy club
and there's like uh
you know i see these
there was these tweets about the comedy
store facebook posts about how i went to
the comedy store and we got covered in
because they don't care about insight
hold on hold on
you're going to a place
where you want to drink
eat
around people and laugh
projectile spit laugh
i mean that's just you're laughing
people are laughing around you you want
to have your mask off you want to eat
and be merry
and you want to blame the place
like yo
take
some personal
responsibility
for yourself
and
stop blaming
you know a pla
you know a private business
that is doing something that is
according to like how covet works
a comedy club ain't the safest place
it's not the safest place
so
that's on you
okay it's on you and to blame the place
like they're supposed to be in charge of
your health and safety now yes
obviously the place can like set up some
like make sure you know do the best
thing best they can but in terms of an
environment where you're around other
people
laughing with your mouth open and
chicken wings and you're drinking
alcohol and you want to blame the
building i have a problem with that
i really do have a problem with that
okay i don't want to get all into that i
do want to get into stuff you know what
something i realize about doing a
podcast which is great is like
this is a good place for me to like work
on
you know some premises my material that
i want to take on stage
you know because
when i first start thinking of material
it comes off a little harsh man
sometimes it's like
because these are my thoughts and then
you have to go well how can i make these
thoughts fun and entertaining but like
on a podcast i don't necessarily have to
do that i don't got to be necessarily
fun and entertaining so much as like uh
it's like you know we're getting the
thoughts out and you'll know the jokes
or like not the jokes but like the funny
moments
you know
the funny moments and i've been thinking
about something because you know i'm
down i'm i'm slimming down and i'm
losing i'm trying to lose some weight
and uh i realize the battle that i'm
fighting
the big the main battle i'm fighting is
i'm fighting obesity
you know obesity is like man this sucker
is a killer man
um
you know
i mean
i even got some facts for y'all you know
obesity you know obesity is just a damn
killer if you look at on the world
health organization it says obesity has
reached an epidemic proportions globally
with at least
2.8
million people dying each year as a
result of being overweight or obese
what
2.8 million people worldwide
2.8 mil do you hear what i said
2.8 million people
and we're not doing anything like we're
not shutting the world down we're not
like you know being like okay nobody can
have hamburgers on wednesdays to to curb
this we're not there's no restrictions
on um you know the butter intake there's
no restrictions on sugar there's like
nothing we're being poisoned you know
what i mean and then again personal
responsibility too we're not even trying
to take care of ourselves until we have
to
man this sucker is crazy
you know i mean it's crazy man and so i
was thinking about this like obesity man
is like
this sucker's like a a shadow
organization man
it's like a shadow organization that's
right in plain sight and nobody's
talking about it like obesity is like
hydra
from from the marvel universe you know
obesity you know what i mean obesity is
is hydra and and shield is body
positivity
you know and
the social justice warrior liberal types
they think they're the avengers
but they're on the wrong side man they
on the wrong side
and so especially when it comes to like
you know when even you like i was
talking about earlier with covid you
know what i mean like you look at covid
man
you look at kovid we blame like all
these deaths and sickness we just we
totally blame covey we're like oh man
cove it's terrible look what it's doing
to people but man when you look at this
[ __ ] according to the um you know the
cdc and stuff man
obesity worsens the outcome from covid
having obesity increases the risk of
severe illnesses from covet people who
are overweight may also be at increased
risk like
we're not we're not given obesity it's
due when it comes to covet i got another
analogy for you
covid is like the iceberg that hit the
titanic
okay
it's the covent is the iceberg that hit
the titanic but obesity is the lack of
lifeboats and safety precautions
on that boat
who
is at fault what's at fault
you know what i mean like
did the people on the titanic die
because they hit an iceberg
to some degree
but more people died because they didn't
have enough safety precautions in place
in the event of an emergency
that's obesity
so you can't sit here and be blaming
covet for everything when we're killing
ourselves because we're not prepared now
obviously if the ship never hit an
iceberg nothing happens so covet is bad
but let's not blame everything on covet
okay
so that's my thoughts with that
you know what i mean so i'm gonna turn
that into some funny material eventually
uh but for now that's uh
you know that that's where we we are
with that you know and i just think that
we're not dealing with that's why i feel
like obesity is like this shadow
organization man you know but they're
live it's in plain sight nobody wants to
talk about it you know it's like there's
a disconnect between
um body positivity and
being an unhealthy fat ass
and from a distance you can't even tell
who's who it just depends on
which one the social justice warriors
want to prop up
because people in our families like i
had an aunt
with hypertension
high blood pressure diabetes
she was fat as hell
you know they might look at her and be
like oh man but then there's lizzo
they look the same
so what are we doing
who we who you know what i mean it
doesn't make any sense to me
here's something else
if i was mcdonald's
if i were mcdonald's
i would put millions of dollars into
body positivity campaigns
like all the fast food restaurants
should get together and be like yo let's
pump out body positivity campaigns
because we got to keep this train
rolling because body positivity
campaigns are in line with
mcdonald's
you know what i mean like day one
mcdonald's wants people to keep keep
looking like that and we're going to
help you look like that so do you feel
good about you come on into mcdonald's
it makes sense to me like they are
you know what i'm saying like
they're right in line with each other
and people don't realize it
anyways
we won't keep going with that i just
wanted to point that out man uh very
interesting uh when you go to like the
cdc and you just look up if you just
just google like obesity and covet and
they have a lot of facts about this man
they have a lot of things about you know
weak community and you know obesity has
become the leading cause of death and
nobody's talking about it
nobody's it's like i tell you it's a
shadow organization nobody is talking
about
um
how obesity affects things because when
you look right now and you know and they
show just the main facts about leading
cause of death one of them is heart
disease it's at the top of the list but
then you look at what causes heart
disease obesity is at the top of that
list so you know it's just something to
think about guys
but uh
but i'm gonna turn the whole [ __ ] into
uh
material and we'll see how it goes you
know what i mean we will see how it goes
all right i just want now let's get into
some fun stuff you know what i mean i
don't want to just already it's like you
know that's what i think what's happened
that's what i think happens with my
podcast when people watch me and they're
just like oh man you're too serious or
whatever you do like that i mean i'm by
myself this is me this is a partial a
portion of my personality you know what
i realize when i go like i go on other
people's podcasts and people love me on
other people's podcasts i realize i'm
like the nate dog of podcasts you know
what i mean
i'm the one you know people
people like me on a track but they don't
want to listen to my album
that's how i feel about uh
my podcast life right now
all right so let's go into some more fun
light-hearted subjects um
uh so i saw that this great art there
was a great interview between um
draymond green and kevin durant
like like it was on i don't know what it
was on but it was actually pretty
fascinating uh our interview
and it really is just about the state of
what's going on like this one says
draymond green's warrior interview with
kevin durant is the inevitable evolution
of sports media
and i thought to myself you know it
really is i mean it's like
you know there's you know there's there
there's good and bad with the internet
there really is you have the good you
have the bad uh you know the bad being
trolls the bad being like you know child
pornography and like uh hate that they
hate that people spew and your bullying
and all that stuff but you know there is
some good too and it's like i just think
for celebrities or people like these
athletes i mean the internet and the way
the media is right now they can tell
their own story from their own words
you know it's like what do you need some
interviewer what do you need like bob
costas or one of those type of guys no
no shade on them i think bob costas is
great and you know he's one of the good
ones but i'm just saying for you know
for instance you don't need like lebron
james if he was gonna do
like if lebron james was gonna do the
decision now would he need jim gray like
right now he has his own platform
his own way like lebron could have just
like went live on on instagram or he
could have went live on youtube he could
have told everybody i'm gonna go live on
youtube at this hour
um you know what i mean and then like
i'm gonna talk about he could have done
it himself you know he's he could have
done it on hbo because he has his own
show his own production company and i
just think like this is like where it is
and the honesty that
um well i don't know if it was
necessarily honest but the conversation
that they had with each other as like
you know uh competitors as friends as
professional athletes
you know they were they were able to be
at a a level of vulnerability that i
don't think they would have with a
person who doesn't play the sport or
just a person who's like in the media
you know what i mean and they got to
some stuff and i just thought it was
very interesting i don't necessarily
agree with the things they were saying
like i you know likes like kevin durant
blamed steve kerr for the reason why he
how they how the organization and steve
kerr dealt with their that little blow
up that um draymond green and kevin
durant had i just i'm just like really
you want to blow up your this this
championship thing for for that i mean
what i don't know
but he's someone that jumps around i'm
not going to be surprised if he leaves
the nets in two years or even a year
who knows so i didn't necessarily agree
but i thought it was fascinating i
thought it was like wow what a great
interview
uh
these two guys and i just think you know
you think about it it's like the whole
media could be like that even stars you
know what i mean like it's like so many
people now have podcasts and these big
huge celebrities are like they have
podcasts and they're inviting people on
their podcast it's like we don't need to
go on oprah you don't need to go on
entertainment tonight you don't need to
go on these things you know it's like
you know you just have your own platform
and then you call your peers and like yo
you want to come on and talk to me and
then you know when you're watching the
podcast how deep people get how
you know
you know what i mean like it's amazing
how you know you you find yourself being
more open with this person that you like
respect or or someone that you feel like
understands you is on your level i think
it's just a different stage and it's
like where are we gonna be and like you
know where are we going to be in five
years when it comes to the to the media
i've talked about this in the past
it's like we don't need critics anymore
man
i mean we literally don't need a person
who is a critic
on a website like they're doing a review
it's not needed as a as a profession i
do reviews
you know what i mean it's just like so
i'm just talking to the small group of
people that watch me and i'm saying hey
here's what i feel about this thing what
do you guys think
you know and then it's like my following
like
i just think like some of these people
that are critics they you look at their
personal
profiles and they got no followers like
no one cares what they actually think so
i don't understand why this website
cares what they think what is their
qualification
other than being an [ __ ] to uh talk
about
you know the way they trash things you
know what i'm saying so i don't know man
it's a weird thing it's like i just
think the evolution is like you know we
don't need that we could do it ourselves
it's like there's enough like rotten
tomatoes is the type of thing where you
go like what do you want to watch a
movie like let's say a movie comes out
and you go and it says
a hundred thousand people
found this movie pretty good
but then there's seven critics who
didn't who are you gonna believe man
who you wanna who do you wanna listen to
do you wanna listen to people like you
or do you wanna listen to these people
that have like some like like some weird
over-intellectualized take
some pretentious take on what they think
is a good movie or not it's like fast
and the furious we know that [ __ ] on
when an oscar we're trying to give it an
oscar but like did you enjoy it
were you entertained like this should be
a level of like hey is this a good
escape movie that i could just go to and
get lost in it i know it ain't it ain't
you know it's not the godfather but it's
a pretty fun movie you know it's like
all right
you just have to decide what you want
like what you're going what you're
looking for like sometimes you know
maybe you are like one of those
pretentious artsy types and you're like
hey i want to go see a movie that i feel
like
is technically sound
like the lighting the sound the acting
the l you know the the cinematography
you want to go to a movie because you
want to be inspired as an artist okay
then talk about it that way but i don't
think you should compare a movie that
isn't trying to be that with a movie
that is that
you know and then you have these award
shows that no one cares about because
we're like all right first of all you're
too political at these reward shows i
don't want to hear your [ __ ] opinions
about what's going on in the world at an
awards show just accept your damn award
and move the hell on you know so you
know so people don't watch that anymore
and then you know so it's like what's
the point what's the point they should
expand the categories you know they
should expand that like guilty pleasure
of oscar you know this is the movie that
i really loved watching but i know it's
not you know whatever you know what i
mean
i don't know man i just feel like i'm
more in line with
when people say oh this was you know
what a fun movie
and then there's so many like you
realize
now that you're more in line with like
the masses than you realize in terms of
like you know if a hundred thousand
people went and saw a movie they said
hey i like this
i would venture to say you're gonna go
and even if you don't like the movie
you're gonna understand why a hundred
thousand people like the movie because
you might be like okay i get it but it
may not be your cup of tea
but to rely on seven pretentious
[ __ ]
at some weird little website or even a
big website where they themselves have
600 followers like no one cares about
their opinion like they're putting out
stuff on their own personal profile and
nobody there isn't
the same mass appeal watching
caring about what they have to say it's
so bizarre you know what i mean so
bizarre
all right so that was that one thing
about draymond green and it's like and
this is what and to go into that about
you know
the the level of sports media you you
also have to know like you get to know
the person's personal taste like if you
watch me all the time you can kind of
get a sense of what you think i'm gonna
like or not like uh you know you get you
know and this is the reason why you
watch me you know you get to know me
you're like okay i want to hear what he
has to say about this and you may be
like i don't agree with that but i
understand like a sort of common sense
approach to what you're saying so you
know i totally get that so another one
is like and this is another example of
that man uh you know
the paul pierce
so paul pierce was talking about lebron
james you know
and he's been um
you know you know he had he said this
thing about lebron james he goes paul
pierce if lebron doesn't win this you
win this year he's not top five all time
and people are clowning him because he's
such a hater
you know what i mean like paul pierce is
such a hater
and it's like so funny to me
[Laughter]
like if you watch
basketball you know like i always think
every time when paul pierce was on the
air before he had his little controversy
and got fired for like saying some dumb
stuff on the internet
like he went live and didn't know he was
live to everybody and he was saying some
really outlandish stuff and so they
fired him
uh
you know it's um
it's like
lebron james literally
put a stop to
boston's
reign
so they the first big three
they won that first championship that
first year
they went seven games every single
series and they won the championship
kevin garnett got it done and then they
never won again okay and i think large
part to that is age and doc rivers i
think we're starting to realize doc
rivers ain't he's not the coach that we
think he is
uh you know
he he had he got lucky with them and i
think kevin i think it is a large part
to kevin kevin garnett i'm saying kevin
garnett kevin garnett would not be
denied he left minnesota he went to
boston he was at a
later stage of his career and he was
like i need this championship and he
willed it you know
uh he willed it to happen
so and i think it was more on him than
it was the rest of the team and doc
rivers but
lebron james
he stopped them
you know he had that 45 point game in
game six of that eastern finals beat
boston i think he beat him the next year
too like
lebron james
you know and paul pierce just
he he he was on a team that had a rich
legacy the celtics with larry bird and
all those guys
and him getting like a second
championship i think would have launched
him into you know the upper echelon of
the boston elite but
right now
he ain't he's not when you think of the
best boston players i don't think he's
even in the top five maybe not even in
the top ten who knows probably probably
but who knows
it's hard to say because so many people
have multiple championships with boston
and you know he would have been that
modern era player to like you know to
make it happen and lebron james is one
of the sole reasons why it didn't happen
so he is a consummate hater he's such a
hater like all the things he says about
lebron james is just like hey hey
hey hey i just like come on man why you
got to be such a hater
all right so this is that time in the
podcast where i have to
pay some bills y'all
and i want to talk about betterhelp.com
you know i love better help i usually do
real world advice from a grown-ass man
and i feel like
you know it's very helpful to talk about
things and you know because a lot of
things in our life interfere with our
happiness and what makes us tick
and you know therapy i highly recommend
it i've gone to therapy i worked on
boundary issues and it doesn't solve
your problems but it helps you organize
them it helps you pinpoint like oh this
might be the cause and you come up with
some coping mechanisms to help you so
better help is great because you can
connect in a safe and private online
environment you send message to a
counselor anytime you get timely
thoughtful responses you can schedule it
weekly look man there's a lot of things
we're all dealing with right now with
covid and depression and
afghanistan and and just the overall
feeling of what's going on in the
country and you might need some help
don't think that you can handle it on
your own or if you're feeling a certain
thing it might be that you need to just
really sit down and talk this stuff out
relationships sleeping you know there's
so many things you can help so anything
you share is confidential and
there's so many people actually now
joining betterhelp that they've
recruited additional counselors in all
50 states listen guys i want you to
start living a happier life today and as
a listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com griffin
join over 1 million people who've taken
charge of their mental health that's
betterhelphelp.com
griffin for 10
off your first month
let's start living a better happier life
all right y'all
we did it
so anyways
um thanks for being here um
you guys uh in the chat right now and
for you guys listening you know later uh
thanks for listening once again you know
again check me out on eric griffin
gaming i game all the time on twitch i
play a lot of call of duty mostly call
of duty i love that game i love warzone
the season five started and i love it i
really love the game you know it's just
such a challenging game and if you guys
don't know about what warzone is
um it's like a a battle royale game
where
you know you're dropping in if you're
playing a solo it's like 150 people and
then like 150 people are logged into
this server and they drop into this like
made-up city and you you you uh
parachute into like parts of the city
and and then there's like gas
that comes and it closes every like two
or three minutes and it closes and it
closes and it closes and it's like who
is left standing
it has you know it's just the rich
graphics and game play and there's so
many things to complain about but
there's so many things that you love and
you're like i say you're playing against
other people so you can do solos duos
trios quads you know it's you and your
friends are playing against other people
and it's just like such a challenging uh
experience so
i really think uh
i really you know if you if you play
video games this is just one of those
games that i think you should play in
like season five is out and i have a lot
of videos up on eric griffin gaming on
on youtube and again like i say i game
daily on twitch when i can i'm about to
start going out of town a lot so i don't
know if i'm gonna be able to
um be on live as much as i am you know
and then we're also going to uh we're
going to i'm actually going to adam
devine's wedding which is a destination
wedding it's going to be out of town so
rachel and i are going we're going to
have a little vacation and i'm for sure
not taking my uh
xbox i can't even imagine going on a
vacation
and having the xbox with me that'll be
just like a nightmare
just the fights i'll get in with my
chick
so
you know it is what it is i don't you
know i normally
i don't normally
you know people comics do a lot of jokes
about destination weddings because it's
like well
but because of covid i mean i totally
get it and because like i am now engaged
and we are you know planning like a
wedding for next year like june whatever
it is like that and now i'm thinking
about it i'm like oh my god
wedding arrangements are a nightmare man
it's like you don't want to invite any i
realize
i realized too is like i know a lot of
people and there's a lot of people that
i that of these people that i know that
i wouldn't invite to my wedding i'm like
i don't because
and let me tell you the hardest part
about
um
having a wedding
i'm looking forward to being married but
i'm not looking forward to a party
and i have my reasons and one of the
main reasons is
my mom has dementia
and it pains me
to think that this is one of these
things that my mom has always wanted you
know i want you to get married i want
you to have kids and so now i'm finally
hearing this moment and my mom isn't of
her right mind to appreciate it and
understand
and it just makes me sad and it's like
my only real
family is my mom you know my only like
she's like like the closest family
member i have other families i you know
shout out to my favorite cousins uh
alyssa and angelique you know these are
my dogs you know they're like my little
sisters
i love them to death and you know and
they're really i'm really close to them
you know and but that's a different type
of relationship that i have with them
that you say you have like your parent
you know my your mom you know
and so it's like it's tough
and so like my girl's parents they want
to pay for the wedding and then it's
just like this thing where it's like
they think that i don't want to get
married it's like no i just i'm just
like i'm not looking forward to this
wedding you know like a wedding is not
the it's not
you know what i mean it's not the same
as being married they are not the same
it's like a graduation you know what i
mean like when you like going to a
graduation isn't for you like when you
graduate your graduation ceremony it's
not for you it's for your family your
graduation ceremony is for people to
celebrate you for them it's not for you
and so
when you don't have family or if you
don't if you feel disconnected from your
family you may not want to be at a
graduation ceremony because you're
sitting up there and you're looking out
at all these people and you know people
are doing the air horns
and they're just like
and you got nobody
you got nobody out there so you're like
oh i'm looking forward to graduating
because now i can move on with my life
but it doesn't mean you have to look
forward to a graduation
that's how i feel about a wedding
just because i'm not looking forward to
a wedding
doesn't mean that i don't want to be
married those two things are not the
same
so
i wanna thank you for the super chat i
just saw that
that's not the same so
it's hard so i have to like find ways to
like you know i gotta just like i just
have to like
get get at peace with it
you know but it i don't know man
you know you know what i'm saying like
it's like it's just it's just one of
those things
you know and so it just like it ticks me
off because
i don't think people take the time to
think about my feelings
you know like it's like when you're
having a wedding it's all about the
bride it's all about you know
it's all about that it's like i don't
have an advocate there's nobody going
hey eric how are you feeling about this
and why are you feeling about this and
so you know i got to i got to have my
podcast here so i could talk to
strangers and like put my thoughts out
in the ether about this but you know
it's not
it's it's not it's not all this cracked
up to be you know but this is like this
societal like
thing that we do that we make it seem
like you have to do this and if you
don't do this you're like you know it's
not real or you're a monster or
something like that
and it's like exactly and i see in the
chat what you're saying it's like as
long as two people are happy i think
that's what's most important i think
when you get family involved in events
like this they [ __ ] it up because they
make it about them
you know what i mean and so and that's
why those kind of ceremonies and things
and parties and things like this it is
about them
it becomes that's why you always hear
about like at weddings like you know
what's a wedding without a family
dust-up or whatever the kind of thing is
it's because you're putting people in a
room that don't necessarily like really
want to spend that amount of time with
each other you know then they think
they're like hey nobody can put aside
their differences to celebrate these
people especially the bride you know
people are you know we've been trained
to you know they've been trained and
inundated with these ideas that hey you
know you have to have a big
wedding and you you know and all this
stuff and you're just kind of like you
know i guess you have to have it like
that but
one thing i'll say for rachel is that
she doesn't necessarily
come off to me like that is like the
biggest thing she wants i think the
thing she really wanted was the ring and
i got it a ring you know
and uh and then most mornings if she
didn't go to sleep with a ring on she
and she takes it off she wakes me up she
hands me the ring proposed to me
[Laughter]
and so i you know i re-repost her i i
propose to her in all different types of
ways you know
that way and i say different things
every time
and literally every time she cries like
every time she gets
swelled with emotions and i think that
that
moment that her and i are sharing
is more important than
some party
that
you know and i have to remember that i'm
saying that not to say don't have it i'm
saying that to remind myself
just be happy with what's happening now
and i can't change
you know how people look at it or i
can't i can't worry about how people
perceive it as long as
you know my girl and i are
happy and healthy and i think that's uh
you know a really important factor in
the whole thing so
yeah i didn't necessarily want to talk
about
that i don't but this is when i do it
live this is like uh you know a a stream
of consciousness that just goes you know
what i mean
just goes
all right i guess we can get back to
like now another serious topic
um
you know
it's it's crazy what's going on in
afghanistan man
even when you just look at the news you
know you just look at the news that's
happening right now
um
where's my screen there we go
you know what i mean you just look at
like
you just look at like what's oh this is
that's not on the screen good
but you just look at like what's going
on there man
all these different stories
of people
of like how we're dealing with this and
what's happening and the people trying
to evacuate and
it's you know it's just
it's crazy to me man because we went
over there 20 years 20 years i didn't
even think about that
20 years
and there's many people especially the
social justice warriors the echo chamber
liberals that as i call them and i have
a lot of comedian friends who are like
that they're just they just want to hear
their own thoughts they're just echo
chambers you know like tell me what i
already think
you know and these are the same people
who are like what are we doing in
afghanistan we've been there for 20
years and what are we doing and what are
we doing
and then we pull out and then all this
[ __ ] is going on and now they're like
the women
what are we gonna do for them it's like
what
you know the crazy part about the united
states we are so spoiled we're so
entitled
we really don't really understand that
this
way of life
we had to fight for it
we didn't just
up and leave england
like hey
this ain't working out thanks for
everything but what we gonna do is we
gonna start our own [ __ ]
so
thank you and goodbye no it didn't work
like that
this was years and years and years of
war
and violence to fight for freedom
you have to fight
for freedom
do you understand that
and these people
that
have completely forgotten our history
and think that every place in the world
is the same and thinks the way we do
you guys are you you really got to open
your eyes
we were over there for 20 years
supposedly training them to fight for
themselves
and we pull out we spend two trillion
dollars we pull out and in four to seven
days the place is overrun and taken over
so the people there
they don't even want to fight for their
own freedom
and we have we we're making ourselves
responsible
like shut up man
y'all have forgotten all of the
different
things that we've gone through to get to
the stage we're at right now to feel
like we're at peace
revolutionary war
you know civil war
you know um the world war one world war
ii like think of all the fighting to get
to the point where we're at right now
and you know we just think that oh yeah
every place else everyone else all the
other countries have their own journey
they got their own journey man they got
their own thing going on and not
everybody wants to live the way we live
and at a certain point we just have to
protect our own borders
we could try
you know we could be like hey
i you know
or if we're gonna be police
then let us do it
you know what i'm saying like we're
handcuffing ourselves too because we're
saying hey
bad stuff is going on over there we need
to go over there hey bubbe but when
you're over there make sure you do this
gently
it's like
there's no gentle war
you know there's no gentle fight for
freedom
okay
in within the country and even then and
even when you know look even in our own
country when we're fighting racial
injustice which is still going on today
in a country that fought so hard for
freedom to the point where we're at
right now we are still fighting for
racial inequality for racial equality
we're still fighting for you know for
the police to to treat people equally
we're in this country so you think a
place like afghanistan who is not as
where we are
that only 20 years they're gonna change
their whole attitude and be like okay
well
they don't want that
you know these people what they're doing
to women and how they feel about women
and we and you think we're the most
sexist country in the world
man i'm telling you
it's tough man
it is it's a tough thing
you know what i mean it's it's it's so
you know i just think like
i understand both sides of the this of
like being like hey there's no
there's no easy way to like you know
pull out of a place that you've been the
bodyguard
you know what i mean
you know it's like you've been to
security yeah you know this whole time
and and the people are like okay great
thanks for being here we're gonna boom
boom boom that you know there was no
real like thought well if they because
after 20 years you think well they're
not gonna leave they're not just gonna
up and leave
and then we up and left and the freaking
taliban was like thanks
we got it from here
ugh
and then
it's crazy all the stuff that's going on
all over the world too man that's the
crazy part too all over the world
there's stuff going on that that's
different like i started to read about
stuff that's going on in australia man
man australia they they got a police
state going on right now you can't leave
they got all these lockdowns and you
can't go out you can't go five meters
away from your house you have to only
talk to people you know
you know you can't go to work you get i
mean it's like i don't know what's going
on over there we don't even care we're
not even thinking about it we're like
so i mean
they're they're protesting the you know
how the how we're handling how we handle
covet
we got the same thing going on here but
not even to that extent so we don't even
know about all the things that are going
on in other places france and australia
and like different germany and all these
different places they got their own set
of problems going on so
and it's like
i don't know man
everything's so politicized everything's
so political that we can't get any
common sense we can't even get any
common ground we can't get like us to
like get together and do what's best for
everyone for for most people for the
majority of people like you know there's
always going to be some outliers you
know you got these like especially with
coven man i mean i i i just i hate
hearing about you know
you hate hearing about people who are
the you know the anti-vaxxer people who
are like dying you know and it's like
there's so many of those stories being
put out where like they're in the
hospital and the hospital workers are
like man these people on their deathbed
going i was wrong
you know what i mean
you just go i mean and then you know
there's part of you that wants to be
like if you're like somebody who's
already been vaccinated and you know you
think like people got to learn their
lesson i mean i mean i get that
sentiment but overall it's still sad man
you know it's a sad situation and it's
because we don't have all the facts like
going back to what i was talking about
earlier
no
no news organization is talking about
the effects of obesity
in the fattest country in the world
we're not talking about how obesity
affects covet we're just let's put a
mask on yeah the mask should be like
don't put hamburgers in your mouth you
know
i don't know man
as a fat fat person myself trying to
work on my health because i have to
because if i don't i'll die
i mean you know i'm i'm in a now a new
unique situation to be like man i should
have been doing this
early on it's like you know one of those
it's like and we have to take personal
responsibility because
the government ain't trying to help it's
not like they're banning sugar it's not
like they're like saying like hey uh you
can only eat fast food on wednesday and
friday
uh you know where uh hey uh
you know
corn syrup no more corn syrup and stuff
um
you know the fda
isn't looking out for our health
they ain't looking out for our health
uh you know they're not
you know what i'm saying they're not
they're putting stuff out you know like
any time you know you know and and this
is the thing that's like we're slowly
killing ourselves by this shadow
organization of
called obesity it's definitely hydra you
know obesity is for sure hydra man and
we're sitting out here thinking that
yeah we got this
we got it baby whoo
you know we gonna beat we gonna beat
you know we yes body positivity look
feel good about you and obesity is like
good
good
welcome to the dark side you know and if
we don't do something about this man
it's only going to get worse it keeps
getting worse and worse and worse but
we're busy politicizing everything and
not talking about things in the way that
we should talk about it
to really make sure that the health and
safety and well-being of our country is
intact and we're just not doing that
we're not doing that everything
everything becomes about being male
everything becomes about being racist
everything becomes about like you know
it's like male talks toxic masculinity
uh
you know white privilege
you know all this
distracting [ __ ]
when we could like really get to the
underlying things about what's going on
in the world you know like there are bad
people doing bad things but it's like
can we delve deeper and find out
how they got into those positions can we
delve deeper and find out like how can
we get good people in good and in these
same positions like it takes some more
what's my favorite word y'all nuance
to the discussion about the problems of
race gender and even sexual orientation
man you know it's like i'm tired of like
fighting about gender
and both sides are fighting like you
know you got these people who are like
you know they want to get rid of male
female and i think it's a deeper
discussion i think it's a deeper
discussion about like yes we've we have
like certain
attributes that we've put on the two
sides that maybe we should take that
away
like you know like wearing a dress and
wearing uh you know a suit pants you
know pants and a shirt and you know ties
and like uh colors pink and blue and if
we take away all those things and we let
people like do what they do
uh you know maybe we wouldn't feel so
strongly about like what's a man and
what so what what's manly and what's you
know womanly and you know we you know we
can we can delve deeper into those
things but like ultimately though i
don't have hate for people but like i do
have an idea of what i think a woman is
and i do have an idea of what i think a
man is and i think we all feel the same
way and then this small small small sect
of society is trying to make us feel bad
about how we feel about it you know if i
say to you hey i'm looking for a woman
we need a woman for this particular
thing and then they're going to be like
no you don't or
you know a transgender person can be
like i am a woman then i could be like
yeah well my wife and i are looking for
a surrogate to have a kid
so
what are we looking for
how do i ask for that to make you
comfortable
how do i ask for that
huh hello anybody
yeah shut up
you know what the hell we're talking
about that's the thing that pisses me
off
you know what we're talking about
we could talk about that in that way and
still be sensitive to
this other side's
feelings
and the things that they're going
through because it's all new
you know it's all new so we have to find
a way to be sensitive to everybody's
feelings but stop acting like you don't
know what we're talking about when we
say woman
when we say man
okay stop acting like you don't know
what the hell we mean you know what we
mean so let's deal with that and then we
can move on to how we can move forward
to make everybody feel comfortable
you know what i mean so what what's the
new language that we can do
to make you feel okay
that's what i need tell me that because
i don't know how to speak
uh to you
because you making me feel like i'm a
monster when i have no ill in my heart
towards how you want to live
so yeah
i'll leave it on that
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying
huh all right well i think uh
i don't know
i think i think we did it
uh
you know let me let me let me get this
going here you know i think we did it um
and
there we go that's my outro music
some free [ __ ] i got on youtube
it's called six feet
off the ground outro
and it's like one of those free things
you can use but anyways guys
i want to i appreciate you being here
every week for the ones that come every
week
um
and you know again catch me live make
sure you like share help me share spread
the show and like i say just i'll
genuinely thanks for being here i don't
thank my fans enough and i really do
appreciate the ones that are just dogs
you guys are road dogs you guys are here
every single week you send me messages
you're like thanks for doing what you do
and i do appreciate you obviously i want
the show to be bigger but if this is as
big as it is ever gonna get i still love
it that's why i keep doing it we're on
episode 148
and we're going strong
and
once again i'll see you next week um i
don't know if i have a guest or not i
don't know what's gonna go on we'll try
to get real world advice from a grown
ass man back and i'm trying to do some
other segments too but
overall
i appreciate you guys and
i will see you
next